En este video vamos a ver algo
que me ha dejado maravillado,
vamos a relacionar las áreas de regiones internas
en cuadriláteros. Empecemos con esta idea. Este
es uno de los teoremas para relacionar áreas de
regiones en cuadriláteros más sorprendente y,
sobre todo, más útil. Imagina que tenemos
un cuadrilátero dividido por dos diagonales,
estas diagonales crean cuatro regiones que
tenemos aquí, las cuales vamos a llamar A,
B, C y D. Este es un cuadrilátero cualquiera,
puede o no ser un paralelogramo, pero para
todo cuadrilátero se cumple que: el producto del
área de la región A por el área de la región B,
es igual al producto del área de la región C
por el área de la región D (A•B = C•D). Así que,
por ejemplo, si el área de la región A vale 3 m²
y el área de la región C vale 4 m² y el área de
la región D vale 15 m², ¿cuánto vale el área de la
región B? Bueno, usando el teorema, tenemos que:
3 m² por el área de la región B es igual a (4 m²)
(15 m²), entonces el área de la región B va a ser
igual a (4 m²) (15 m²) / 3 m², y bueno, 15 / 3
es 5, 5 x 4 es 20, y estos metros cuadrados se
cancelan y me queda simplemente 20 m². Ahora bien,
siguiendo la misma idea de este teorema, ¿qué
pasaría si tuviéramos un trapecio? Observa ahora
cómo son las áreas de las regiones que determinan
las diagonales. Bueno, esta vez se cumple que el
área de la región A va a ser igual al área de la
región B, y siguiendo la misma idea, si tuviéramos
un paralelogramo, entonces tenemos que el área de
la región A va a ser igual al área de la región
B, que va a ser igual al área de la región C,
que va a ser igual al área de la región D. Todas
las áreas son iguales en un paralelogramo. Bien,
ahora veamos el siguiente teorema que relaciona
áreas de regiones internas de cuadriláteros.
Tenemos un cuadrilátero cualquiera, como este,
y ahora vamos a dividir cada uno de sus lados en
dos secciones iguales, es decir, este es el punto
medio del primer lado, entonces estas distancias
son iguales; este es el punto medio del segundo
lado, entonces estas distancias son iguales;
este es el punto medio del tercer lado, entonces
estas otras dos distancias son iguales, y este
es el punto medio del cuarto lado, entonces estas
distancias son iguales. Ahora, unamos los puntos
medios de cada lado formando otro cuadrilátero
como este. Lo realmente impresionante es que
para todo cuadrilátero se cumple que: el área
de la región B es igual al área total entre 2;
es decir, el área del cuadrilátero B, que
acabamos de dibujar, siempre es la mitad del
área total para todo cuadrilátero. ¡Increíble!
Esto se cumple para todo cuadrilátero mientras
los vértices del cuadrilátero interno corten los
lados del cuadrilátero exterior en dos longitudes
iguales. Si sabemos que la región B tiene un área
de 8 m², entonces, con nuestra expresión que dice
que el área de la región B = A total/2, podemos
encontrar el área total, dicho de otra manera:
8 m² = A total/2, o lo que es lo mismo, A
total = 2 • (8 m²), que es 16 m². Bien. Otra
relación entre las áreas de regiones internas o
dentro de un cuadrilátero -y ojo, ten cuidado,
ya que esta vez hablaremos de paralelogramos-
es la siguiente: si tenemos un paralelogramo
(recordemos que un paralelogramo es un
cuadrilátero cuyos lados opuestos son paralelos),
bien, y tomamos a P como un punto cualquiera en
uno de sus lados, y trazamos las líneas entre
los vértices opuestos y el punto P, entonces
puedes observar que se generan tres regiones:
a la primera región interna le llamaremos M, a
la segunda región interna le llamaremos L y a la
tercera región interna le llamaremos N. Entonces
el teorema 3 nos dice que se cumple lo siguiente:
el área de la región interna L es la mitad del
área total sin importar donde pongamos el punto
P. Lo podríamos poner aquí o aquí o aquí, o
dicho de otra manera, podemos pensarlo así:
el área de la región interna L es igual a la suma
de las áreas de las regiones internas M y N. Este
resultado me parece sorprendente porque el punto
P puede estar en cualquier parte del lado opuesto.
Sólo ten cuidado, ya que esto se cumple sólo
para paralelogramos, así que es importante que lo
recuerdes. Bien, por último, veamos otra relación
entre las áreas de regiones internas también de
paralelogramos, pero esta vez utilizaremos un
punto interior. Si en un paralelogramo trazamos
líneas desde cada vértice hasta un punto interno
O, entonces se cumple que el área de la región
interna M más el área de la región interna N es
igual al área total dividida entre 2. Por ejemplo,
si nos dijeran que M = 5 u² y N = 3 u²
¿cuál es el área total del paralelogramo?
Bueno, siguiendo la expresión, tenemos que
el área de la región interna M, que vale 5
u² más el área de la región interna N, que vale
3 u², es igual al área total de entre 2: 5 u² + 3
u² es lo mismo que 8 u², y esto es igual al A
total/2, o dicho de otra manera: el A total = 2
• 8 u² lo que es 16 u². Y eso es todo por este
video. Ahora ya sabemos calcular el área de
cuadriláteros y cómo se relacionan algunas áreas
de regiones dentro de ellos. Hasta la próxima.